foreign
in Memphis hey Dustin welcome to the
show
hey how are y'all doing today doing good
doing great how can we help
yes so uh I'm originally come into a
good sum of money and I'm trying to
figure out what I should do with it cool
how much
a little over 300 000. would have come
where did that come from
uh I played the stock I've been playing
the stock market since about 18 years
old and when Cobra hit I won it big
I love that you're talking about this as
though it's gambling because that's
exactly what it is
oh my goodness oh Dustin okay
congrats on your windfall
and congrats on winning your lottery
that's amazing so 300 000 can you tell
me a little bit more about your just
overall income situation do you have
debt like
tell me more do you have what's your
income I'll probably have about seventy
thousand dollars left on my house I'll
probably have about 25 000 left in my
car
and that's about it I know that other
than that the job I do
I uh help operate and set up new
locations for less for a certain
restaurant and
I'll make about 35 000 after taxes every
year okay do you have a family
yes I have well family hasn't Just Me
Myself and of course my mother and my
brothers and sisters okay okay yes that
does count as family I should have said
you have a wife and kids amazing amazing
so you know do you have any money in
savings by the way I didn't ask that
um currently that's the I pulled out of
that I pulled that out of the town's
mess in one of my Banks I've got another
six month emergency fund as well as ten
thousand dollars and another bank that I
don't touch
great job very good Dustin you're set up
extremely well
um so yeah are you so you're going to be
cashing out these stocks is that yeah
okay I cashed out before it fell because
my look it would fall out yeah so you
know what I would do is there's a really
three parts to what I would do here I
mean definitely you're going to be able
to pay off all your debt and become debt
free so I want you to do that I want you
to save some of it for that six months
of emergency so if there's any more that
you need to add to that I want to do
that and then I want to make sure that
you're working with just a team of
people to make sure that you're managing
this money and that you're prepared for
any taxes that you might need to pay on
this because it's a lot of money
um and Beyond the taxes the tax have
been paid on it I'll cash this out a
year ago oh okay okay on it since gotcha
okay and I you know I have a question
what about retirement do you have any is
there anything that you're contributing
normally to retirement at this point
because if not I saw that just yet I'm
only 23 years old so I'm trying to
figure out what else to do next okay so
we're paying off this debt we're getting
you set up with a great accountant a
great Tax Advisor a great smartvestor
and I want you to quit playing single
stocks and I want you to get invested in
good growth stock mutual funds okay from
now on you're investing 15 of your
income absolutely yep 401ks Roth Ras
Dustin I think is right in your future
and congratulations man so young and
doing it but don't let that be a habit
because it doesn't always work out that
way okay so let's play it safe for
retirement but congratulations Dustin
well done